blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so i want to start today talking
about inflation
um we are now starting to see inflation
rise more quickly than it has in quite
some time and republicans are going
absolutely crazy
thinking that this vindicates their 30
years of claims that oh no
now that the government has done some
stimulus
we are going to see this inflationary
spiral
which will destroy the economy they've
been saying it for 30 years and it
hasn't happened
and now they are turning this recent
new employ inflation number not
employment number
into what they claim is a vindication of
the claims they've been making for the
last 30 years and somehow this
also relates to joe biden and we're
going to get back to that
in a moment but i think it's important
to understand the kind of context here
the u.s has been i guess you could say
the word is blessed
with very low inflation for a long time
steady but low
inflation uh the way most economists
believe is ideal
for an economy and we'll talk about why
a little bit later
the consumer price index has now
increased in april
compared to a year earlier by 4.2
percent
and this is the most in a year-over-year
comparison dating all the way back to
september
of 2008 so in about 13 years when we
compare uh
one month in one year to that same month
the year before
this is the biggest change we've seen
about in the last 13 years
economists surveyed by dow jones were
looking for an increase of 3.6 percent
it came in above that at 4.2 percent
now this is really really important to
understand before we even get into the
macroeconomic analysis
i do think we are seeing some prices
truly increase in some areas lumber for
example
as far as the research i've done shows
lumber is getting more expensive
in a real way not just because
of a pandemic-related statistical
artifact
but much of this uh increase
is merely a pandemic-related statistical
artifact uh
gas prices for example going up in late
2020
and so far in 2021 aside from this
temporary
pipeline shutdown which is being
resolved uh is
is back on as as of today um we
saw one of the biggest demand collapses
for gasoline
in 2020 because the country shut down
people weren't driving people weren't
commuting
and then relative to that we saw a huge
demand increase
later in 2020 and particularly in 2021
so the numbers we just received for
inflation
are april of 2021 compared to april of
2020.
in april of 2020 we had one of the
biggest macroeconomic
demand collapses in a very long time i
can't
i don't remember when we had such a
demand collapse because it was the first
full
month of covet shutdown so prices
collapsed
now we are comparing to april of 2020
and so when you look at the internals of
what's driving this price increase
its energy prices again hugely demand
driven
oil prices collapsed in the second
quarter of 2020 where at one point
oil futures had even gone negative now
people want to travel again people want
to drive people want to fly
used car and truck prices are up which
makes sense as some people
are going back to commuting one car
families are going back to two cars
all of the people who got their first
who would have gotten their first jobs
and potentially got in a car during the
pandemic
uh but were either working from home or
didn't even get that first job until now
many of them now need vehicles to start
getting to and from work so this is
primarily what we call a base
rate effect when we compare inflation
last month to inflation at a time when
lots of prices had collapsed
you are going to see a relative price
increase that may not really be
representative
of uh what is going on in the economy
now the good news
is that the fed seems to know this and
has said
we're not going to do anything in the
immediate as a result of these inflation
numbers
one month of numbers with the heart of
the pandemic as the base number that
we're comparing to april of 2020
it really doesn't give you much to work
with the inflation
target remains 2 for the year the fed
still
expects that yearly inflation year over
year
will be roughly 2 percent so for now the
fed isn't going to raise rates they're
not going to make any other changes
now that all being said there are actual
shortages
of some construction materials that will
probably remain for the foreseeable
future and that's going to cost more
renovations are going to cost more new
home prices may well cost more
um now let me address a couple of other
bigger picture things first
you might be saying david sir why is the
target 2
inflation like why is some inflation
better than none shouldn't we be
targeting zero inflation
this is a very debated economic issue
but fundamentally
if you have deflation or you have
stagnant prices meaning no change
whatsoever
it's an incentive for people to wait to
purchase things
now this is a standard economic analysis
if you want to apply a totally different
line of thinking to the economy a more
socialistic line of thinking communistic
of course you're going to have a
different perspective but in the kind of
traditional economic
thinking which is of course only
partially right we know now that
classical economics is only tells us
part of the story
the idea is if you think things will
cost more in the future
you are incentivized to buy them now
before the prices go up you get it for
less now and you can start using it now
why would you wait
that is where growth and employment and
wages come from
uh if you think things will be cheaper
in the future or at least that they
won't be more expensive
you might wait to see if prices go down
and then it creates a deflationary
spiral because you're waiting to buy
prices do go down businesses have to lay
people off since they're not selling
stuff because remember
you're waiting to buy they don't have
the employees that get laid off don't
have money to buy stuff so prices go
down
more and you can have what's called a
deflationary spiral
japan experienced this for a long period
of time it's neoclassical at basic
economic thinking
but that's part of the working theory
obviously too much inflation is bad
because then
people's purchasing power goes down they
can't afford stuff either so
that's where you get to this kind of
happy medium of we want a little bit of
inflation
and predictably so now last thing on
this
republicans are now claiming vindication
we told you
the stimulus would make prices go up and
things would get unaffordable
they said this when biden did the 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus
they didn't say this when trump did both
of his
stimulus packages they have been saying
it for 30 years including in 2009 when
obama did tarp etc etc the
truth is inflation throughout all of
that government spending
has been very well controlled and very
modest and very reasonable
this seems to be primarily an artifact
of comparing numbers
to the absolute lull the doldrums of the
pandemic
and that's it there's really i'm finding
myself not even really having more to
say
uh about that piece because it is so
transparently untrue so that's the
latest on inflation
we'll watch the numbers we will soon
have numbers in early june we'll have
numbers comparing
may 2021 to may 2020 and then we'll have
to uh
at that point we'll be able to get a
more well-rounded picture of what's
going on
yesterday there was some very
interesting hearings in washington dc
uh sort of primarily about the janu what
happened on january 6th and a little bit
later we're going to get to the comments
from donald trump's former acting
uh secretary of defense about when
donald trump finally did say
okay let's bring in the national guard
to clean up what's going on on january
6. we'll get to that later
but one of the really interesting i
don't know if we would call it a side
story it's really
kind of a main story that came out
yesterday during the testimony
is that the biden administration's top
law enforcement officials
including merrick garland the attorney
general
including homeland security secretary
mallorcas and a number of others they
said in no
uncertain terms that uh white
supremacists are the greatest domestic
terrorist threat within the united
states now
if you've been watching my show for a
while or if you're familiar with the
data
on domestic terrorism this would not be
a surprise to you
the story that the right has been
telling for a very long time
is that american muslims
or immigrants from muslim countries even
left-wing eco-terrorists in some
versions of the story are
really the great domestic threat but
when you look at the data
and you look at domestic extremism
incidents you very quickly understand
that the biggest threat in the united
states indeed is
white supremacists which sometimes
overlap with these sort of patriot
and sovereign citizen anti-government
type movements
that's really where the bulk of the
threat comes from and merrick garland
said yesterday to lawmakers quote
domestic violent extremists pose an
elevated threat in 2021
and in the fbi's view the top
domestic violent extremist threat we
face
comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority
of the white race now
what you are also uh starting to see
uh is that republicans are having to
find a new way to even talk about this
and uh senator richard shelby for
example
instead of focusing on the level of
threat is trying to make the
administration seem
biased in its priorities and when it was
richard shelby's turn to talk to merrick
garland
he asked are you investigating for
example
the protests in portland oregon with the
same
vigor that you're investigating what
happened on january 6. the implication
and
wrapped up in that is the implication
and the assumption
that the portland pro protests were
left-wing
violence whereas i guess he sort of
may be conceding that the january 6th
riots were right-wing violence
and merrick garland responded very well
and said quote
we don't care what the ideology is
violations of law are pursued and
they're prosecuted
i think it's fair to say that in my
career as a judge and in law enforcement
i have not seen a more dangerous threat
to democracy
than the invasion of the capital um that
doesn't mean we don't focus on other
threats as well
and so we we are starting to see this
kind of shift
uh among the right where it's becoming
essentially undeniable
that the bulk of the incidents are these
right-wing patriot
sovereign citizen anti-government um
uh uh and and certainly white
supremacist racially ethnically
religiously motivated
events but what republicans are now kind
of going back to and it's good that
they're having to change what they're
saying even though it's still bogus
is okay well maybe these are the numbers
but what about the attention that's
being paid there are political decisions
that are being made about who to
investigate who to charge etc
and that should be in that should be
looked into but it's sort of like a
welcome to our world moment this is what
many of us have been saying about the
judicial justice for a system for a very
very long
time when you look at who actually
uh does drugs has drugs deals drugs
versus who is prosecuted who is policed
what are the sentences that are given
out we've been pointing out that there's
a lack of equity there for a very long
time
along racial lines for sure among class
lines as well as we've discussed so
now unable to continue denying
the empirical reality of where the
greatest number of threats come from
they are pushed back to having to make
an argument the left has been making
about the justice system for a very long
time
i don't know where this will go uh but
yesterday's hearings were very
interesting because they touched on a
lot of these different
um tangential topics they're big topics
but tangential
to the it to the day of january 6th
including investigative priorities for
federal law enforcement including what
the biggest threats are
and a little bit later in the show we
will get to
some of the testimony about the
nitty-gritty of what happened on january
6th
send me your thoughts on this you can
find me on twitter at deepakman and
remember that on monday memorial day
it's not this monday
it's not the next monday i think it's
the one after that
monday memorial day we're doing a
one-day membership special single day
membership
bomb if you've been thinking adam and
maybe maybe i'll sign up someday
memorial day is the day to do it because
it will be a beautiful discount okay if
you want to be notified on memorial day
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
an audience
funded program primarily and you can
sign up today at joinpacman.com you'll
get the daily bonus show as well as the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
the members only newsletter occasional
invites to members only town halls
there's a lot there
uh grab one of those memberships at
jointpakman.com also uh please join
for free here i'm not selling anything
often i am selling things in this case
i'm not
there are almost 31 000 of our viewers
and listeners currently subscribed to
the david pakman show
subreddit it's free it's moderated
it's a great central place to discuss
the issues
talked about on the show and other
issues important to you
you can find it at davidpakman.com
reddit one user and i spotted this this
morning asked
should tucker carlson be deplatformed of
course not by the government
but by fox news not that they would ever
do such a thing i know this subreddit
has many
free speech absolutists but where do we
draw the line
tucker is literally spreading extremely
dangerous
anti-vaccine propaganda that will lead
to the death of his own audience you
know what's funny is
the the reason fox news like like any of
these networks for the most part
fox news is amoral fox news is concerned
with
um what revenue does
tucker's program bring in um what
prestige
does tucker's program provide fox news
what access
does tucker's program give us to people
in positions of power now
on the first question about the
profitability of tucker carlson on fox
news
it's actually probably not as high as
some people think because increasingly
tucker's advertisers
have abandoned him and if you watch the
show on broadcast tv which i never do
but i've gotten reports about the ads on
it
um it's increasingly like very
non-prestigious brands and advertisers
so to me it seems as though the tucker
carlson program
has good ratings gives fox news
attention and and sort of free publicity
because others talk about the crazy
things tucker is saying i don't know how
profitable the program
actually is for fox news but the point
here is
fox news would only consider getting rid
of tucker carlson
if it provided a net negative to fox
news they don't care
about the dangerous anti-vaccine
propaganda that tucker carlson is
spreading
unless and that's why this post is
clever if his
own audience starts to die such that
nobody's left alive to walk the show
to watch the show they all of a sudden
would care you know while on some level
it's probably true that the behavior
tucker encourages will lead to some
deaths i don't think it'll be enough to
really impact tucker carlson's audience
so
i have no expectation that fox news is
going to do
anything about tucker carlson's program
it's been on for years
it does well from the standpoint of
ratings and fox news quite frankly
doesn't really care what he says
as long as it doesn't become a real
problem for them either
furthering the financial issues or in
some other way
so i my view would be on this
rather than imposing that a network fire
tucker
or whatever the ideal mechanism
would be people realize that it's a
completely vapid
show it's not news it's just kind of
like weird entertainment for some people
um
and that they just should tune out and
then it'll naturally resolve itself i
mean maybe
at some point if nobody's watching fox
news will say i guess we're wrapping the
show
i would rather it come from the bottom
up than the top down
and i won't i have no expectation that
we're going to see anything from the top
down from fox news they just don't seem
to care
another user on the subreddit asked a
very good question which is what
happened to the gnome chomsky interview
david has been teasing it for a while
but it just never happened
yeah you know back in early march and i
said when i teased it
i said i'm i'm running a risk here a lot
of people in the audience don't realize
how frequently
interviews get rescheduled and postponed
or even cancelled
because it was exciting i announced in
early march we're scheduled to have noam
chomsky on
later that month i think it was going to
be march
uh in the second half of march and uh
people were very excited but
unfortunately it did get rescheduled
and it was actually rescheduled to next
week
and unfortunately that has now been
rescheduled into early june
this is very common uh particularly the
more well-known the guest is the more
common this is there are interviews that
we've had four or five even reschedules
on
uh so i'm hoping it'll happen soon and
so you know it was interesting to me and
i knew the audience would find it
interesting so i took the risk of
mentioning this was scheduled
i maybe i just shouldn't have said
anything at all nobody would be asking
about it and then hopefully in early
june there would just be
an interview with noam chomsky but it is
on the calendar for the first few days
of june
and uh hopefully hopefully it will
actually happen
join the discussion on the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t this is
super interesting we've been talking
about declining
interest in vaccination uh the people
who already have been vaccinated
are mostly people who really wanted to
be vaccinated and now we have a
situation where supply is starting to
exceed demand
and government state governments need to
figure out
new ways to get people interested in
getting vaccinated because remember no
matter what anybody tells you there's no
mandatory vaccination per governments
there are certain schools that will say
if you want to come to campus you have
to go and get a vaccine
or if you want to work for us you have
to go and get a vaccine
but there are no mandatory vaccinations
per the federal
state or municipal governments but you
have an
interest from governments state
governments they want to be open and
they want to be open in a way where
people aren't going to get sick because
that's what's best for business so
they're thinking of new ways to
encourage people to get vaccinated
republican ohio governor mike dewine
is creating five one million dollar
basically lottery rewards for people who
get vaccinated
five people who get vaccinated in ohio
are going to win a million dollars each
the republican governor announced this
last night
all vaccinated adults will be eligible
to enter a lottery that will pay out one
million dollars
each to five winners starting uh just a
couple of weeks from today march 20
may 26th rather and separately dewine is
also offering
five vaccinated teenagers full ride
scholarships
to the state's public universities
including tuition
room board and textbooks the textbooks
are key oftentimes you hear
free tuition right but what about the
thousands of dollars for textbooks
it will even include that uh dewine said
in a statewide address quote i know some
may say dewine you're crazy
the million dollar drawing idea of yours
is a waste of money
but truly the real waste at this point
in the pandemic
when the vaccine is readily available to
anyone who wants it
is a life lost to covid 19.
i think that this is absolutely
fantastic and understand
that um you have money
set aside already in a number of
different states
uh for vaccination and for getting
people vaccinated in public awareness
campaigns
this is a way of using five million of
that dollars
instead of on billboards and
tv ads or whatever the case may be
you're saying well let's just give five
million plus the cost of tuition to the
five teenagers to some people
and i think it's absolutely fantastic
the lottery payout will be funded
using federal coronavirus relief money
allocated to the states states and
localities have been given this money by
the treasury they've been given wide
discretion about how to spend it
and mike dewine is saying let's give it
to some people
there are questions as to how effective
public health officials think that this
is going to be
tara smith who teaches epidemiology at
kent state university
says there's some research to suggest
small financial incentives could
increase vaccine rates
but that just giving a million dollars
to five people
uh may not work because the perceived um
odds of winning are relatively low and
that if there is a criticism
of it that was my thought which is
a million dollars for five people uh
that's a lot
but what about giving a hundred that
thousand dollars to 50 people it's the
same amount of money but i think the
perceived odds of winning will be higher
and of course they will be they would be
10 times higher
let's listen to mike dewine announcing
this and talking about this yesterday
on may 26th we will announce a winner of
a separate drawing for adults
adults who have received at least their
first dose of the vaccine
this announcement will occur each
wednesday for five
weeks and the winner each wednesday
will receive one million dollars
so i think it's a great idea the again
the only change
i might make is instead of five people
get a million dollars each i might make
it fifty people get a hundred thousand
dollars and
uh the you know the alternative that was
also proposed is
just pay everyone who gets the vaccine
figure out how many people
how many adults you have um divide up
the five million dollar prize pool what
does it work out to
give that to everybody and then for the
unspoken for money at the end of the
campaign
maybe then that becomes a sort of like a
lottery or something like that a lot of
different ways to do this
i think it's a i have no moral problems
with it at all
and if it's effective i'm 100 for it let
me know your thoughts
let me know if you would go about it a
slightly different way
and we'll have more coverage of what
different states are doing to encourage
vaccination
on our instagram page which you can find
at davidpakmanshow
you can also find me on instagram at
david.pakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world
famous bonus show every single day just
for members
as well as commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
today i'm going to be speaking with jim
freeman uh
who is author of the book rich thanks to
racism how the ultra wealthy profit from
racial injustice and also director
of the social movement support lab at
the university of denver
jim it's so great to have you on today
thanks so much for having me david
so i mean to start with let's get people
into sort of the thesis and idea of the
book
in what ways can racism be
profitable how do people monetize racism
yeah i mean you know the reason i wrote
the book is i wanted to introduce this
idea of
strategic racism right so um
particularly after last summer there's a
lot
a lot more understanding of systemic
racism
um which is which is good and exciting
but the problem is
that um not many people understand what
and who
stand in the way of dismantling that um
and there's also a problem too i think
with the term which is which is sort of
vague and impersonal
right it makes it seem like systemic
racism is this natural occurrence it's
just
sort of part of our society so i wanted
to introduce this idea of systemic
racism
to demonstrate to people that
there are people who are profiting from
it there are people who are racism
profiteers in this country
that there is intentionality behind
these efforts
um because you know even when we do
think that there's people on the other
side of this fight
we think about the alt-right and those
kind of folks but that's not who's been
passing all these laws that are
responsible for
systemic racism they're not the ones who
are doing the heavy lifting
in defending or expanding these policies
so
you know my work as a civil rights
lawyer has been with
the communities that are most impacted
by systemic racism black and brown
communities i've been working with those
communities for
for 20 years and so i've seen up close
what this looks like
and how devastating it is and you know
what that really means in practice is
that
these corporate wall street executives
these ultra wealthy
billionaires they make huge investments
in these think tanks and advocacy
organizations and media outlets
that have been instrumental in
preserving defending and expanding these
dynamics such as what we see in the
criminal justice system such as what we
see in education and immigration
and and like you say they are profoundly
profitable these dynamics for the
ultimate wealthy
they make money off of mass
incarceration and immigrant detention
and immigration enforcement and school
privatization
and they also you know they pay less in
taxes when we as a society choose to
dehumanize
people rather than meeting their basic
human needs
and then you know one thing that became
very clear i think to a lot of folks
last summer is that
systemic racism particularly you know
the mass criminalization and
incarceration system that we have
it's extremely effective at controlling
us at dividing us
and causing us not to recognize our
common interests
but we really saw that in how police
were used to
um to really stamp down um political
protest
so all those dynamics really helped
maintain the status quo
help the ultra wealthy maintain their
political and economic power
um and those are just you know i think
some of the ways that they profit from
these dynamics
yeah so and and that i mean that gives
us a good introduction to
a lot of different industries and
corporations that are sort of directly
connected to a lot of these issues i'd
be curious about your thoughts before we
go back to that
about i don't know i don't want to use
the term more like benign or pedestrian
corporations but just things more
associated with day-to-day like for
example starbucks and other companies
that last summer started to make a big
show of we're going to do implicit bias
training
and all of our managers and maybe even
employees
are going to go through a course and so
on and so forth
i've always felt that that was
essentially a pr decision and and
number one at its face it didn't really
pass the sniff test for me but really
what got me thinking that
was i've not really found evidence that
that type of training
for a company like starbucks just to
pick one or others
really gets at the root of some of what
is causing these issues to begin with so
i know that we're this is kind of a
slight deviation from what you
you introduced to us but what's your
thought about that as
as a source of profit or at least of
positive pr
yeah i mean you know you make an
excellent point which is
you know last summer we had what seems
like virtually every corporation in
america coming out with a statement
denouncing systemic racism
yes um you know proclaiming that black
lives matter
um and yet here we are you know nine
months later
and what have those corporations done
to actually dismantle these systems
right to
not just like you say do um
these sort of superficial diversity
efforts
or to you know donate some small
tiny percentage of their profits to
black owned businesses i'm talking about
you know real efforts to to address
these issues that are
harming and even killing um people in
black and brown communities
they're nowhere to be found and in fact
um for the most part there's there
they continue to be on the opposite side
of these fights so
you know one thing that um that i talk a
lot about
is is you know those
we've had those types of efforts forever
you know where
we we talk about how we're making
progress right we're taking steps
forward
we've been doing that for over a hundred
years you know what i mean
and i it's got to be clear by now that
you know those things aren't bad per se
but they're not even close to being
enough
um and you know
i think the question for us is how many
more people are we going to allow to be
harmed
how many more lives are we going to
allow to be taken while we are content
not to actually solve the problem but to
merely make
progress so i think when it comes to
racial justice we need to remove the
word
progress from our vocabulary you know i
think it's time to advance
real solutions but to do so i think it's
going to require many more people
understanding
how and why corporate america and wall
street
are able to profit from other people's
pain and we're going to need many more
white people in particular to understand
how their struggles are deeply
interconnected with the struggles of
people of color
so that they recognize that the the
fight for racial justice is also their
fight now when you talk about that
interconnection
i i'm i'm leading here in the sense that
i don't think you're talking about a
sort of class reductionism of just
realizing that
in the same ways that a lot of these
racial issues relate to class
that can also be a factor for you're
talking about a different type of
interconnection am i right
i am yeah i mean the i i think there's
there's there's different types of
interconnection but but one was really
only
made apparent to me when i was
researching and writing the book
um which is you know as i was diving in
so the book is really an effort to sort
of follow the money behind
systemic racism or what i call strategic
racism to understand
exactly where it's coming from um and
and the ideology behind it but as i was
doing that
it was really eye-opening for me because
you know
as i was learning more about where this
money was coming and how strategic these
investments were i also realized how
heavily invested the ultra wealthy are
and pushing a political agenda that's
been deeply harmful
to white americans as well not in the
same ways of course and not always at
the same levels
frequently not but um but what i say
is that like if white people examine the
reasons that their lives are far more
difficult than they need to be
they will likely eventually run into the
same set of organizations and
individuals who are leading the
opposition against
quality yeah so you know i for one was
astonished to discover
just how enormous an influence the ultra
wealthy have on my life
and on every other white person i know
um but then yes beyond that like we all
need to get to the point where we can
clearly see that
education inequities and mass
criminalization and anti-immigrant
policies and all these other racial
justice issues
don't just harm those who attend the
under-resourced schools or suffer the
effects of what we're policing or
or face the prospect of being being
deported you know if we examine our
lives carefully
we will all find evidence of harm caused
by the reverberations
from these unjust systems and on the
flip side we also need to recognize
that you know people who are fighting
for racial justice aren't trying to
like we're often treated like we're
trying to like ruin the world
but the reality is we're trying to build
a better world that benefits all people
um and that when we do address these
issues of systemic racism
it doesn't just help people of color who
have the burden
of those racial inequities lifted off
them we all stand to benefit
when our neighbors are able to live
higher quality lives um
and the really rot of injustice is
purged from our systems
what are some examples of where you
think the most notable progress has been
made like in the last 10 to 15 years on
these issues
well i you know i think the most um
exciting progress
um uh happening within um
most recent memory is is around law
enforcement and the criminal justice
system
and people are really starting to
interrogate
um this issue of um police and the role
that they
serve and the role that they should
serve right and people are asking
questions
really important questions about how we
actually keep
our our communities safe
and healthy and why have we tasked
so much the police departments with so
much
that really they're they're ill-equipped
to handle i mean
you know that that's certainly true in
in black and brown communities but
but it's true beyond that too i mean i
think we have to recognize
how frankly how deeply we've lied
to communities of color over the year i
mean for 40 years basically
what u.s policymakers have been saying
to black and brown communities
is is this we can we can best keep you
safe by being tough on crime
by flooding your communities with police
officers by using stop and frisk by
employing
broken windows policing and cracking
down on low level offenses by putting
police in schools
by locking up people at the highest
rates anywhere in the world
um by doing the type of policing frankly
that killed george floyd and dante
wright and so many others
and all along the consistent message has
been that these were the most effective
strategies for improving public safety
but there is no evidence for that you
know there are no heavily policed and
high incarceration communities that are
flourishing
socially economically culturally there
are just none
it's a null set um so it really is
a deep deep lie that we've been telling
those communities for many years and
folks are starting to see through it
and i think that's very exciting when
you think about
some of the decisions that are made by
corporations that are not directly
involved for
example like an incarceration as you
talked about um
or some some of these other specific
areas um
it seems that there is a kind of vicious
cycle
where even you know uh a
chain restaurant based on how it decides
where to put new restaurants
and as a result where jobs are created
and what impact that has
on the food choices of people that may
otherwise live in food deserts i mean a
lot of these things seem very complex to
me because
one can find reasons to think that
almost any decision to give a really
specific example
think of a fast food chain that says hey
you know what we do well
in poor neighborhoods that are relative
food deserts in terms of other options
there's not that many grocery stores or
healthier
health healthier alternatives and so
that's where we're going to go
and this worsens the health of the
people in the neighborhood by making
okay
the counter though is hey they're
creating some jobs in that neighborhood
though if
every such business decided we're not
going to set up shop in this
neighborhood
that's a hundred that's 200 however many
jobs that that aren't brought there
and it very quickly becomes sort of like
cloudy how should what is the what
should be the top
level interpretation of some of these
business decisions that relate to race
how do we disaggregate that and start to
pick apart something
something like that
yeah i mean i think um
i think it's certainly true that we have
to become
much more disciplined as a country
in um analyzing all of those decisions
and the policies that influence those
decisions through the lens of race
through the lens of
systemic racism and i would suggest
strategic racism too
um because and i'll go back to criminal
justice because
we were talking about it um you know
the last summer when george floyd was
killed when he was murdered
um we were told over and over again that
it was a wake-up call for the nation
right um but we never actually woke up
right um if we had we would have started
to have
we would have come together around real
solutions to those issues around the
vastly oversized and violent
criminal justice system that's used
within black and white communities as a
catch-all solution
for a huge variety of behaviors we
didn't actually do that we didn't even
really start that conversation
um but it's not because we don't know
how
it's not because they don't have a fix
like we do
um and there is um we don't do it
because there's a very well-funded
opposition that stands in the way
right so you have organizations like
alec
representing hundreds of the largest
corporations in the u.s working for
decades to pass those various
tough on crime policies you have folks
like the koch brothers
and all these other billionaires who
have been pouring tens of
billions of dollars into various
right-wing think tanks and advocacy
organizations that have been pushing
this agenda and still do today
you have one of those think tanks the
heritage foundation
who after the uprising last summer
against systemic racism
what they decided to do was launch a
back the blue campaign a back to blue
police pledge that has now been signed
by 200 members of congress
so that's 200 members of congress who
have vowed to continue supporting the
status quo in law enforcement right and
then
one of those members of congress senator
tom cotton one of the most powerful
republicans in the country
who tweets out a couple weeks ago that
in the us we have a major under
incarceration problem
so for me that's what modern day racism
looks like
is that we implement these public
policies that we know
are going to inflict needless harm on
large groups of people that we know will
perpetuate racial inequities
that we know will lead to people getting
killed and then when that harm becomes
apparent
we fail to address it appropriately and
significant part because it's
economically beneficial
for the ultra wealthy so i think that's
true in criminal justice i think that's
true in education i think that's true in
in public health um and
so what we really need to do is um if
we're going to address those issues we
really need to prioritize that
and lift up those issues and
collectively start looking at these
issues through the lens of race
so that we can start to design our
public policies
in a way that moves us towards the just
and equitable society that
that all people deserve uh the book
is rich thanks to racism how the ultra
wealthy
profit from racial injustice we've been
speaking with the book's author
jim freeman uh jim so great having you
on and i really appreciate your time
today
thank you so much for having me david
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show so earlier in
the show
we talked about the hearings that took
place yesterday
primarily about the january 6th trump
riots and we spoke about
merrick garland and other biden
officials
explaining in very clear terms white
supremacists
are the top domestic terror threat that
wasn't really the main focus of these
hearings the main focus of these
hearings was actually
what on earth happened on january 6th
and one of the big questions about
january 6th has been
did trump get asked to deploy the
national guard early
and refused did donald trump not
think about it what exactly explained
the delay where we were still watching
in the 4 pm eastern hour and there were
no national guard and the riots had been
going on for hours
protesters and rioters and
insurrectionists had breached the
capitol building
people had already died etc etc
well yesterday during testimony and this
is just unbelievable trump's
former acting secretary of defense
confirmed that donald trump did not
approve
the plan to deploy the national guard
until mike pence called him
more than three hours after the capitol
riot
began yesterday uh
this was the testimony from chris miller
chris miller was trump's acting defense
secretary
for that last period of the trump
administration
and he said that it was a more than
three
hour delay from when the capital riot
started
to when donald trump actually authorized
the national guard to go in
and of course we know that it took a
while for the national guard to actually
get on site it was already
uh starting to really become evening
when that really took place
and it took a phone call from mike pence
convincing him to do it
uh before he was actually willing to
sign off on that
um at first former acting defense
secretary chris miller testified
that he gave full authorization to
deploy members of the national guard
at 3pm which was about two hours
remember right around 1 p.m eastern we
were all
watching it live we were streaming live
about 1 pm is when the breach
started 3 p.m is initially what chris
miller
said uh was the timing miller was then
questioned by new york congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
and uh she started going more
specifically into the timeline of
january 6th
and then we eventually learned that
actually the national guard was not
authorized
to go to the capitol until 4 32
p.m eastern time and the delay
uh it's a little nebulous what the delay
even was part of it was coming up with a
plan
for exactly how it would be done and so
on and so forth but what's really
interesting is that
the the testimony revealed a
conversation between miller and mike
pence
at 408 pm and aoc
asked did pence direct you to clear the
building
and miller said well i had a very brief
conversation with mike pence
where uh we we agreed that the building
would be cleared but the order to
actually
do it was not issued until later
after a conversation with the mayor of
washington dc
after a conversation with speaker nancy
pelosi after a conversation with senate
at the time it was senate minority
leader
uh chuck schumer and uh it was
three hours after the mayor of dc
actually asked for that deployment so
there are really a couple of
possibilities here
neither of them is particularly good and
i would kind of summarize them
as either incompetence or what some some
might call treason
others might call indifference i don't
know
one possibility is trump and his
executive branch
realized the danger of what was going on
right away
they understood the urgency of getting
the national guard in quickly
but it took them three and a half hours
to do it because they were either
inept or they couldn't figure out how to
do it or
they were slow or whatever so that makes
them weak that makes them incompetent
that makes them
everything that they showed us they are
during the trump administration that's
one
possibility the second possibility is in
a sense maybe even worse
which is that trump knew exactly what
was going on
on january 6 starting at 1 pm and we
believe that he did because
we we are aware of the fact that he was
everybody at the white house was
watching what was going on
up and that he chose to delay
or not to send national guard to the
capitol
uh because of the political orientation
of the people who were writing which
were trump's supporters
and of course that unfortunately seems
to me the more likely explanation and
the reason i say that is
we know that donald trump and everybody
at the white house were watching what
was going on
we have reports that trump was
increasingly getting
agitated and annoyed that the
writers looked low class and as trump
supporters
made donald trump look bad which is
absolutely
something you only say if you have a an
understanding of what it is that is
going on and so
if you ask me was this incompetence or
was this a malicious
uh attitude i probably lean towards the
malicious attitude based on everything i
know
um if you are coming away with this from
this
uh with a different perspective let me
know but every time we learn
something new every time there's a new
revelation
it points not only to incompetence
by the trump administration yes there
was plenty of incompetence
but it points to an uncaring malicious
and in some cases borderline treasonous
perspective
to what was going on that day on january
6th
uh this is just an unbelievable
instance of spin when it comes to
january 6. so
we've talked a lot about this hearing
that took place yesterday we started
at the beginning of the show with the
statements made by biden administration
officials about the greatest domestic
terror threat in the united states
which merrick garland and others believe
is white supremacist
domestic terror and i believe the
numbers confirm that that's the case
we also learned just in the last segment
because of donald trump's former
acting secretary of defense
that more than three hours went by
between when the riots started and when
there was finally an authorization given
for the national guard to clear the
capital we then
saw a questioning from republican
congressman jody heiss
where he argued that the real victims on
january 6th
it wasn't the american people it wasn't
uh
the police in washington dc the real
victims on january 6 says jody heiss
were trumpists who were there in support
of donald trump
i know uh republican congressman jody
heiss is not exactly a brilliant
guy and this is the case he tried to
make during yesterday's hearings
you really have to be capable of some
incredible
revisionist history and departures from
logic
to even try to claim this but jody heist
tries
i'm going to play some of the lead up
here in this video
and then look at how he tries to portray
the trump
rioters as the real victims between 110
and 115 president trump ends his speech
and uh tells attendees to peacefully and
patriotically
make their voices heard at the capitol
about 150
the capital is breached now in this
timeline it would have been about two
o'clock
before the earliest uh attendees of
trump's speech could have arrived
at the capitol so the capital is
attacked
at the uh right shortly after the
president begins his speech
it's breached before individuals could
have gotten there
where is the the real narrative
in all of that another narrative i want
to bring up
is that the the the media claims that
the tragic death of
officer brian signing was a result of
pro-trump
mobs bashing his skull with the fire
extinguisher
which we all know now did not happen
officer cygnet uh his autopsy revealed
that he suffered no blunt trauma in fact
his mother has since come out saying he
died of a stroke
in fact it was trump supporters who lost
their lives
that day not trump supporters who were
taking the lives of others
you go down the list here ashley babbitt
was shot and killed by a capitol police
officer
kevin greeson suffered a heart attack um
roseanne boylan reportedly was crushed
by rioters
and benjamin phillips died of a stroke
so the narrative needs to be cleared up
the truth matters
the people he's naming that died died
because they chose to be there in direct
violation of the law
i don't think any death is to be
celebrated here
people who have been watching the show
know that that's always been my
perspective
but look at the people that he's naming
he names ashley babbitt who was shot by
police well that's true
babbitt was one of the many military
service members who went to the riots
against the law trespassing police
officers have been cleared of wrongdoing
in her death
she was shot while trying to breach
doors within the capitol she was already
trespassing
she has already broken the law merely by
being in there she was trying to breach
further doors in the capitol and the
officer has been cleared
because he believed he was acting in
self-defense in the defense of members
of congress that he was sworn to protect
in any other scenario these
right-wingers would be saying that was a
justifiable police shooting in this case
they're saying
the trumpists were the victims here uh
he mentions kevin greeson kevin greeson
suffered a heart attack that's true
uh kevin greeson was there suffered a
heart attack
reportedly after tasing himself while
allegedly trying to steal a painting
from the capitol he shouldn't even have
been there he was committing a crime by
being there
he got his hands on a taser he tased
himself and subsequently had a heart
attack
that's not a trump supporter being a
victim that's
a criminal for whom their criminal acts
went wrong and we're not celebrating the
death
but to say that that proves that the
trumpists are victims
not a very accurate statement to make
jody heiss mentioned
roseanne boyland roseanne boyland was
crushed by rioters that is completely
true she was crushed
by a stampede of trumpists of which she
was apart
as they were all breaking into the
capital it's sad
but why was she there she was there
breaking the law along with these other
trumpets who trampled her
it's horrible but that's what happened
uh and then lastly jody heiss mentions
benjamin phillips benjamin phillips
died of a stroke he says that's true he
was there breaking the law as well he
wasn't killed by antifa
he wasn't killed by police and to frame
trumpists as
victims who were minding their own
business
just looking at the capital and then
were killed
either by police or by antifa or left
wingers
to frame them that way rather than as
the perpetrators that they are of a
seditious attempt to overturn the
election is just pathetic
but jody heiss is exactly the type of
guy who would try it i'm not going to
give you his full
kind of greatest hits you can go back in
our
uh archives and find some of the
horrible things that jody heiss has said
over the last decade
but it's a degree of spin that should
really make anybody dizzy it's a sort of
war is peace freedom is slavery like
it's that type
of misinformation these were not invited
guests
who were just looking at a painting at
the capitol
and then they were run over by a mob
they were trespassing
as part of that mob and i'm trying to
remember the line
that conservatives often use after
police shootings at least as it refers
to ashley babbitt
and they say stuff like you know if they
just followed the law
and orders from police no one would
nobody would have gotten shot hurt or
killed or whatever the case may be
that it applies to ashley babbitt i'm
not glad she died
but this is the the the logic that they
give us
whenever there's a police shooting that
we look at and we say that seems insane
that seems like the police did something
wrong they just they they were breaking
the law already they were criminals they
weren't listening to what police were
saying
and also by the way the the version of
events that jody heiss
is kind of trying to present here um
it's almost like he doesn't realize
there's video of the entire thing
we we saw how it all went down uh and it
makes it even more pathetic but he
doesn't care and this guy really is one
of the most pathetic members of congress
out there just check out
go to my youtube channel just go to
youtube and type jody heist david pakman
and you'll see his long track record of
absurdity we have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192
david p this is kind of a funny
voicemail i've been saying
in in a serious way in a genuine way
i'm not sure if matt gates gets indicted
the investigation is heating back up and
we're looking at whether he
was involved in child sex trafficking
and many other crimes um
i i don't know that he gets indicted
that's not what this caller thinks take
a listen to this
hi david i agree with virtually
everything you say
every day well one of the funniest
things you ever said
was at about 7 55 pm central time
on wednesday saying that
we don't know whether matt gates is
going to be indicted or not
right i don't know if you were just
hedging or what but
he's going down and there's no if ands
or buts
he's done it's just a matter of when
thanks keep up the good work yeah i was
not
hedging um if this is the united states
where we have two justice systems and
the reality is that
even being an unhinged and delusional
member of congress
you're still a member of congress and
there's a certain amount of privilege
that that confers
and in all of those cases i hesitate to
assume
that there are going to be legal
consequences um
so no i was not hedging we'll see if you
are right
we'll see if you're right we will see if
he gets indicted we have a great bonus
show for you today elon musk tweeted
last night that tesla is not going to
continue accepting bitcoin for
tesla vehicles and it tanked the price
of bitcoin
and we are going to talk about the
implications long-term
term and short term we are also finding
as if you didn't know from what's been
going on for the last year
there is a trust problem when it comes
to public health officials
in the united states it's
disproportionately a problem from the
american right
as you probably would guess and we will
also talk about the sort of
red line or line in the sand that
republicans are drawing
for joe biden and they did it in this
oval office meeting that took place
yesterday so much to discuss
all of those stories and more when
producer pat joins me on today's bonus
show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com we'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman